can you see this
part okay so
you want to
avoid that 45 degree angle because
that's where all my attacks are
okay
and
if you need to sometimes you can't
identify 45 degree angle
try to keep your shoulders below
or on that side of where my belt is
okay so if you do that again
and you see
you're right there
okay and as you went up
dude do the mistake again
go we'll say you see
do it again right there and that's when
i can do the knee pull
you're off to the races okay
so
as you're doing the drill don't just go
through it and take advantage of
a lot of stuff's been taken out keep
those caveats in mind
okay
and then on this
now this is a little different from what
you're doing okay
so
what what you don't want
is for him to snag your foot
right into half guard
you see
and what actually gives them that
is that knee there
so
you're smelling the
the mouth too
much
and that's where it gets it
so this technique
i'm going to open it up
you're going to kind of pass through a
modified neon belly you see
and then the knee slides down
here
you have to watch because you you think
you're doing it but you actually pivoted
on this side
and that's going to give him that hook
when he tries to get it you're going to
get it
and you're good it's over here
so leaving it open
this technique goes like this
okay you see that difference
oh
i'm
here move
pop
okay
shoulder shoulder line shoulder line
cook with that other leg cook with your
left leg too
grab them
shoulder line
so
working my technique
this this hand this hand
isn't just for me
okay
um
a lot of people
have a training scar
and he's going to stay on the ground
and then that leads to another training
scar
that i don't have to try to keep him on
the ground to get that
so
we don't we don't really have that
problem here because
when we start going
a little more live he wants to try to
get off the ground you see that
um but in these drills at the beginner
levels he's not he's being constrained
to stay in position and then you're
milking it
because he's not trying to get up do you
see so your post was
holding you up but not trapping him do
you get it so when you when when i get
to this level he he knows he lost closed
guard do you see and i'm starting to
climb the positional hierarchy so he he
needs to not be why
why put himself in a position
where
he's on the defensive do you see
if i get
past this
then he now has to worry about
reversing or escaping side control
well why not not get in a position where
you have to escape or reverse side
control and so
when he sees this you can see he can he
can just shrimp out and i can't stop
that leg do you see and so he could do
the triangle get up from there i'm
in trouble okay
uh and he can also always come back in
and attack go to the go to the butterfly
guard so he'll he'll pull himself out
just enough to come back in
do you see
okay so
part part of it is while we're doing
some keyhole
don't take advantage that
he's just lying laying there okay
so
this arm here
has to control
that hip so he's doing the shrimp and
you you get it just enough where
you're in
okay
you can kind of think of it as
uh
almost like a parkour parkour move so
coming around
and it's
okay you get that as opposed to this
you're 80 years old coming down the
stairs and it's a handrail okay it's not
that it's like poo like a desk
when you see in the
movies they jump over the desk or
something over the hood of a car okay
so
you and but it goes here above
that hip and tight
tight okay
so boom
in jump
okay
and weight is down
down
um
and you see i already have
the underhook
for the other technique that i want i'm
already isolating this arm okay
down and forward
and feel for his diaphragm
make it uncomfortable
okay
and then instead of going
here
i'm going to move him around
and bring this knee to the other post on
this other hip
so i'm going to move him around
till his hip
hits that knee that i left in place
you see
i don't want to go like that that's when
he's going to move
so i'm going to bring his hip to this
bottom knee
bring his hip
there it is
and you can see
what that did to his head and neck
and i still have the underhook
so you know we're not doing it but
here's where you can get
your trachea crushes and some carotids
and even a neck crank okay
with from leg straight
and this is where
i'm coming up so i you
i'm going to let this arm out so you can
tap
when i'm doing the maneuver
you see that that was part of the
mounting
do you see that it's posterior
so part of the mounting
boom
he wants me out of this position
and look i clearing the
underhook using the underhook now
okay
technique goes over
and i'm going to grab him with my knee
on my right leg
and the heel
of my left leg
you guys are leaving this dead
here
now i come
base
back into the mountain
you can see how
it's done just a little different so
if you want a and b to touch
there's two ways move a to b
or move b to a well you guys keep doing
the other way okay
so let's start putting this together
tight on the poster space on the post
okay so you're doing the first
correction we gave with your knee is
sliding over
she's going to catch your foot
okay but then you can't fall off and
there's no weight on her your weight is
on your right hand and your right knee
yeah do you see how your knee came over
you see how high your bottom is
so i got here
okay i'm gonna keep things loose a
little bit
okay
when i come off
you have to go for it okay
you have to trust
that uh she can't get your leg
so you're not she's gonna be defending
and all this kind of stuff okay
and uh so she's defending not letting
you in right
uh you just shoved this up
right there
that was all i needed do you see that
okay um you have to trust this version i
know you want to do the other versions
but you want to mix those versions with
this version okay so when we're just
working this version
you have to let go of oh i don't like
their legs okay
got it
you understand okay
so
when i get here
i'm just gonna trust i'm gonna open it
up
okay
i just have to trust that
you can't get that leg like that you see
that
so you can try to you can try to get
that leg okay
i'm just gonna trust
that she can't get
and part of it is
that i'm ripping through this thing
you see
okay
um
but
you cannot
fall
off
do you see
you're going to
flip flip over rip through it
but
you're going to end up on her diagonal
and she's clenched between your
knee and foot
right here
okay not
here you see that
right here
and then
okay
so
go over
the apex
of the ark
to about the 45
and then grab onto them
with your legs
okay
don't
fly past it
and hit the other
three o'clock gang okay
um
so
no
okay again
in all the movements
remember that in some way you need kihon
waza but in another way kihon maza is is
an obstacle that's why you have shuha
do you understand that and the first
part
the first thing you have to do
is to realize that your mind is is
love's form your first mind aspect loves
form it sees the world like that okay
and so the first tool you want to use is
pay attention
to
the
silence between the notes
okay the silence between the notes so
when you listen to a song you hear
but that makes sense only because of the
silence no one ever goes
to the silence part you see that we
always hum the other part we don't do
the pause so
in
your first mind aspect here same thing
it focuses on
those moves that you're recognizing so
the knee part on the belly you see but
the silence is all the stuff that you
did
before you got there and all the stuff
you did going to do after you got there
do you understand
and one of those silences
is
she
should constantly be uncomfortable
do you understand uh and some people
at lower levels
just tap out from those silent notes
because you're just up there
uncomfortable and they don't like it
um
but what tends to happen on most people
is
except very very highly skilled people
is they almost want you to get past that
silent note
back to
the tone because they too work with
first mind aspects
do you understand that so uh
they want just get on the mount because
this silent part between the mountains
is killing me do you and then that's
much easier to mount when the person
wants you to play the note you want to
play the note they want to hear the note
it's perfect do you understand okay so
um
when
we're coming around
right we're just opening it up so when
i'm coming around
this thing
her neck
has a hinge
do you understand so feel this
do you see that okay so uh
this is from not posting here lazily
and laying
on her diaphragm so if you come around
i'll take it off again
watch this knee
there's no
this knee just has to be below
her ability to start like an elbow knee
escape do you see that
so
instead of posting on it and resting on
it
and resting on this elbow
they just sort of hover
they're discovering and i am purposely
where that
diaphragm has to work i'm not down here
you see i purposefully i'll feel where
her
rib cage starts and then this is where i
pass through she's like when she feels
that it's going off she goes yes and
she'll want to hear the note okay so i'm
here like this
this leg is not bracing it's not holding
me up it's very
relaxed and i'm just here okay
and then we're going to come around and
now i'm going to attack the neck
okay but not with my bicep
with my
leg
so this arm stays here
and it's moving do you see how it's
doing that that's about all i can get
without
really huffing and puffing on the arm
and then
my body's doing it
you see
the core is a lot stronger
i come around and now that neck is
really
close to
the other arm
and if you can hear her breathing even
bring that camera close
you see and i'm cranking
this whole thing so i start to drop my
weight and she doesn't like that
so when she feels the relief
she's happy
for that
maneuver
without realizing she's happy because
you're just speaking to her first fine
aspect okay
so uh
you can take the camera
and then um
lay down
and then another i don't know if this
will work but i want to show you because
a lot of you
it feels like it's a terrible crank
and then a lot of you squeeze that f and
use your arms but that's not the
technique okay so uh let's just try
you're gonna lay on
on him
face up on him
no like
like this
you get it
okay
so
uh
it's not that i'm
gonna lift him
this this leg
this leg
is going to
turn him
you see
this leg turns
so it doesn't take any straight it just
keeps turning
you see that
so together these guys are like you can
get
[Laughter]
how much do you weigh 200
170.
it's almost 400 pounds you see
so because i'm watching some of you and
you're working out with either people
that are just above your weight
or even lower than your weight and you
cannot turn them
and you cannot get the neck crank
without this and it's because
you didn't pay attention
so you're going under
it's just like
uh
as you're passing through you use your
idimi naga hand
you do you're saying you're going to use
your demi dog this inward spiral do you
see
don't come here and grab it
this is the inner spiral and then
my leg
that brought this hip to this knee
brings this hand to this hand
got it my leg does it
so
comes in
goes around with the idimi nage and you
see how my leg is bringing it
to the other hand
you see that
and this leg press
it's it's it's like almost like a magic
trick because although you weigh like
400 pounds i'm not lifting 400 pounds
i'm turn spinning 400 pounds
uh
using the distal ends of your lever
in place
do you see that
with a very very powerful engine in my
leg
okay
and then you get the neck crank
and um
and when you're really rolling
people will they don't realize it but
they just want you off and on to the
next note because they've been trained
to recognize notes okay all right so
let's
get this going
all right for you okay so i got opening
up the technique again i'm going for it
we'll catch him here and now i'm gonna
go to the
to the mouth okay
it's almost it reminds me a lot of
sutemi waza you you have to trust
uh
the
situation as opposed to
uh that you're posting do you see so a
lot of times you can't do sutemi waza
because
uh you want to do it incrementally you
want to lower yourself incrementally and
then the throw doesn't work well same
thing you want to get in position
incrementally okay what you want to do
what you want to do is have faith in
this technique that i'm here like this
and i'm stuck on him okay
uh with my leverage okay so i don't have
uh any of the bass and let's say he
wants to push me off do you see but i'm
gonna just do it like this so just go
ahead there's some resistance
that i'm offering just with my
positioning you see
but the weight is on on him
so when i go
i'm going to trust all of that
and not
post
you trust all all of that
is on him
so the butt stays down on him
okay
and you don't
come to your knees
do you see that okay
so
the weight
is on him
your hands are doing other things
widening your base
keeping the underhooks in place
other attacks right
because they're not holding you up and
your knees are not holding you up okay
learn to
see him as the mat what you want to do
with the map
do with him
okay
so again just just play with it
he's the mat
he's the matt
the lower lower lower get your get your
body down
he's the mat
i wouldn't let go of that under hook on
the other side so he doesn't tap your
knee and you could set up other things
on him on him this leg is just
hanging and
not lifting it's just resting right now
it's not being used
everything's on him okay
and then we came around we'll do the
turn we're going to stay at this angle
because the camera's there okay
so i have this
hook
you get it
all right
this arm
okay the first it's it's very simple
this is energy
and you're gonna go around the energy so
don't you don't push into his energy
okay
you're gonna do clearing techniques but
i would
if you do clearing techniques with
understanding how to create an angle of
deviation so angle deviation plus angle
of deflection is the best versus one or
the other okay so as he's pushing he's
trying to stop you from doing that i'm
just going to roll
around his heel palm because it's not
it's not his fingers it's his heel palm
that he's pushing with so i'm gonna go
ahead and push i'm gonna roll over the
heel palm
and push hard
until i'm on the fingers
and it'll be like he's not even
there
do you understand
what's going to happen is you're going
to feel his resistance what do we do in
the first mind aspect we push into that
but you want to
roll over it
this way okay
it's no different than he's he's you're
doing all your grabbing techniques
and you want to
crank this thing over
right or you could just move do you see
and then you have a technique like that
do you understand so
he's grabbing right
and it's his knuckles
do you see that's my the energy okay
go around it
and then you can do these techniques
okay so same thing here
he's gonna he's gonna stop so this one's
kind of crushed so he can't really push
on he doesn't have the leverage okay
the arm is out here and my head's
tapping it
this one
okay
just
keep the
path going
and go to the fingers
you know
be like he wasn't you'll think he wasn't
pushing on me okay as i as i'm doing the
maneuver so this arm still doing the db
noggin
over
okay
all right so
uh let's start
playing with the silences and your uke
is going to
add that hip push
this does not mean you let go of the
underhook
on the other side okay
go
fill it turn it
same stuff
i'm gonna help you now grab
way talking
lean forward well i'm gonna help you so
don't resist
you're gonna lean forward nope
you're gonna turn this shoulder down
you got it
there's the arm over here wait just
relax
okay
you see the difference okay the other
one was easy peasy
okay i was like uh
building an egyptian pyramid with
prehistoric tools just leverage okay so
it's just leverage
all right we'll let you come around
so he's doing his job
you see the knees in
we'll come around any slice
get in position again you don't even
need this you you just need to trust
okay
so i'm gonna try it again don't
lean here
down
hold here don't worry
even this is leverage enough
this this is better than a shorter arm
here
i'm gonna push
okay
all right we're coming through
don't start doing that
to keep that arm
you want to post on it and it starts to
as you move forward post on it like you
wanted to
just ever so slightly as you move
forward you're starting to rotate
so depose yourself okay here we are
so you cannot push into it
you have to go around it
as you're doing the maneuver
nope
you're pushing into my shoulder
go around the heel palm to the face okay
wait
i'm gonna help you again
you're going to rotate yourself don't
come up
turn this hip
past six o'clock
past six o'clock keep turning it keep
turning it keep turning it keep turning
it past six o'clock
nope
okay here
got it extend your arm
how much you weigh
push extend extended arm
ready okay
am i ever gonna get this no okay even
this strength difference
so
i take out the slack
i'm gonna go around it look at the yin
yield
you see
yin yield
around it
do you understand
so
it's jujitsu non-contestation
don't push into that thing
your
it's not jiu-jitsu if you if you
uh address it by overpowering it
can you overpower it eventually you
could
you know if the weight strength and size
difference
but
you could see
that
we're in a spectrum where i can't even
overpower you
got it and if you have a weapon
and you just need that little delay to
get the other hand out
got it
so
um
you got a couple of things it's not very
marshall
if you're overpowering people because
you have to only wait for big huge
opportunities where they're big huge
smaller than you
or
you could also be motivated by i want to
learn the art this is the heart
okay and so you go around points of
resistance not pushing on points of
resistance okay so depending on where
they put that heel palm the concept
remains the same
you got to get around the heel palm
and you might have to
turn way more
you see
then the then the kihon told you to
well
the keyhole didn't tell you how far to
turn and told you
what you have to do okay and then our
first mine aspect we only know how to
play that note
we can't
be like a jazz master and do different
things with that note okay all right
let's try it again i'm gonna do it again
okay so again he's just using the
principle he's doing things with the
note so
in order to get his hip
past the heel palm he he's gonna do a
back step that's what he like to do it's
the same note
you see same exact note okay did you see
it that time okay
okay so i i got around
and he's got that resistance
and again
i the angle deviation always sets up
angle of deflection
it's always a beginner mistake to go to
the deflection part first okay so for
example you know look
okay but it's much easier with the
deviation do you see how i did that
so
here i'm still gonna go around it
but i'm gonna he's gonna he's gonna be
pushing
you ha you're gonna go around it
you got it and then this knee comes here
and then clears it
and i'm going to take
uh
advantage
of him isolating the arm on his own
do you get it which helps me
so
i got i'll end up with one arm isolated
you can't do this maneuver if you don't
do the deviation okay
so i can't get it there
but with a slight deviation i can get it
there we'll
clear it
and now i have
two arms isolated which means this arm
is very
vulnerable
i
okay
which also means i can set up my angles
of attack
here
boom
okay
uh
let's see if the angle of
deflection
will do what it does on most beginners
it detracts from the angle of deviation
so let's just start from the knee slice
and
really give them something
and see if they can find a way of
gaining that and maintaining that angle
of deflection without having to force it
okay let's try
take some yeah there you go
good isolate it go to the figure four
let's go let's go
pull that in
that's enough good get it good pass it
good
get your elbow in there
get your elbow in his neck there you go
let's smooth that out i tried again
that's it
good
get your head down do it again
pull it in
good
i'll always start with the first uh
catch wrestling move and then go to the
figure four got it
okay take off that resistance dude don't
push into it so you're gonna rotate
around the heel palm maybe you need the
back step right
rotate around don't don't go for the
angle of deflection until you take some
heat off of that
pressure point
turn your hips is how you do it
no you missed
okay
don't don't start don't try using it yet
just lay it in place
don't
don't try using it it's just laying
there
start to turn your hips
pass it to the other leg step over the
forearm with your left
shin
let's go
oh you had lost that underhook didn't
you
you had to go chase that arm
pull it in first
you're here
again
you'll have to watch it later because
you
you guys made the mistake of
having the angled deflection take away
from your angle of deviation so this is
for those these guys okay so
he's pushing he's pushing he's pushing
i'm gonna go
under the other way
he's pushing
i'll go here
you see how i did that
he's driving driving
oh
under it
and now you're in them
again
his my fear cycles
but as he goes so i'm coming around
right
and he's gonna find the hip
and you you will think that he never
pushed on me do you see how it was
that smooth okay
it's the same thing
if he's he's here like this and he's
doing a push
you can tell he was pushing on but he
pushes and you can't tell and everyone
goes oh that's fake do you understand
he wasn't pushing he was i just wasn't
there
to manifest his push okay
and so as we're coming around
he's he's really driving i'm gonna come
around he's really driving you can't
tell that they already got disneyland
you see that
okay so
uh you guys will work on that the rest
of you will continue trying to
keep the angle deviation manifested with
the angle of deflection
okay so just on the figure four part
so the first thing
that i'm going to try to do is get that
ball and socket lock okay so i'm moving
this in
this way
that's the first thing i try to do okay
i don't try to go here
i don't want her to extend her arm she
still has a lot of leverage yeah yes
i'll have other techniques
but it's better to find those other
techniques when she's deep in
the do you get it so
when when i'm trying this and she's
strong enough to blow through it wow
it's gonna be that much better on do you
understand then if i'm here
and she goes up
so always have them deep in the weeds
and they have to try to escape from deep
in the weeds okay so the first move this
whole thing comes in home this way and
again a lot of people will tap out on
that okay
um
if if you can't like i don't know why i
gotta look at each of your individual
techniques but most of you are not doing
it so the other thing you can that will
help you
is you can turn turn this do you see
look what it did to her elbow
brought it closer and you see and then
you're that much closer all right
and you see how when i
first grab it i haven't grabbed i just
have it locked cause i'm way over the
the uh
the axis
okay the apex on the circumference
and so it kind of is doing
the same thing all right but if you're
here like this
you'll turn it it'll bring it in you
bring that in first and then you start
going through the technique okay
um
do you understand no nobody should be at
this perfect right angle no you
shouldn't have that that we're trying to
move past this okay
all right